this is one of the biggest guitar
factories in the United States Taylor
guitars was founded by Bob Taylor and
Kurt lists Doug in 1974 that's fairly
new considering some of its competitors
like Gibson or Martin guitars today big
music names like Taylor Swift Jason Mraz
and Zac Brown strung to the tune of a
taylor guitar hi I'm Caroline and today
we're taking you inside the Taylor
guitars factory where they combine
craftsmanship and automation to produce
hundreds of guitars a day the company
has two factories one in El Cajon
California and the other in Tecate
Mexico in 2017 they made over 102
million dollars in revenues currently
we're producing over 720 guitars a day
between both of our factories were
slated to build over 160,000 guitars
this year alone
[Music]
Taylor guitars range between $350 to
more than $9,000 so why such a high
price tag well a big factor is the type
of wood and materials used they
currently have over 35 species of wood
in house to choose from their Factory in
El Cajon makes their guitars out of all
solid wood instead of laminate
construction
[Applause]
some models require advanced woodworking
techniques or greater decorated detail
work which can also increase the price
[Applause]
if the guitar is well-maintained the
sound will continue to improve as the
guitars would ages making it sound
richer and more resonant the factory
runs 24 hours a day five days a week
they have over 900 employees building
guitars with the help of some robotics
we blend robotics and automation with
lots of handwork
I think automation is great first and
foremost it's very important to continue
to advance the factory moving forward
the one thing we pride ourselves on is
we've never replaced an employee with
any automation
we've always deployed those employees
into other areas or into the same
department which has allowed us to
increase our production capacity
[Music]